bonjour michel krif bonjour ravi de vous
retrouver dans la matinale darty france
alors voir est tenté de répondre à cette
question est ce que il ya eu des mots
peut-il être perçu comme une revanche
sur la société civile je crois que eric
zemmour c'est une dynamique qui est en
train de devenir une arithmétique 1 vous
l'avez rappelé il grappille des points
dans les sondages au point de talonner
marine le pen il n'est qu'à sept points
de marine le pen à trois points
seulement de xavier bertrand alors je
pense que derrière l'idéologie qu'ils
portent il y a des éléments de caractère
qui font que les français peuvent être
fasciné par cet homme c'est un homme bon
qui dégage une grande assurance des
convictions fortes et peut-être pour
employer un langage
plus précis il incarne le parler vrai
par rapport à un monde politique est
censé porter plutôt la langue la langue
de bois voilà donc je pense que le
parler vrai le fait qu'il apparaisse
comme un homme de lentilles système par
rapport même à marine le pen parce que
marine le pen veut aussi incarné
lentilles système est elle est dans le
système voilà donc eric zemmour est
quelqu'un de différent et je crois que
cette différence séduit toujours on peut
se rappeler évidemment les tentations
d'yves montand en 1988 d'être candidat
et un peu avant la candidature de
coluche qui a quand même
grimper jusqu'à 16% même un petit peu
plus un pays qui commençait à effrayer
évidemment le mot le monde politique on
oublie aussi en 1965 l'humoriste pierre
dac a été un temps candidat et
l'entourage du général de gaulle lui a
dit quand même lui a fait comprendre que
ce n'était pas forcément une bonne idée
mais au fond est ce que les français
finalement il bien ces candidats qui
viennent d'un autre secteur que celui du
monde politique je pense surtout qu'il y
à un discrédit profond du monde
politique je crois quand les français
regardent eux évidemment les combats les
duels dans le cadre de primaires ou de
non primaire d'ailleurs bon je pense que
ça les laisse de plus en plus
indifférent je pense que les français
veulent aujourd'hui un profond
changement voilà et il aime la
radicalité des propos avec eric zemmour
blanc c'est blanc blanc ce n'est pas
noir
voile alors
bon donc
donc il ya cette fascination
effectivement de gens de gens différents
je crois qu'eric zemmour c'est cesser la
différence voilà et donc c'est
l'appartenance à la société civile c'est
à dire quelqu'un qui n'est pas affilié
du tout haut au monde politique c'est
vrai qu'on pourrait penser à sandrine
rousseau chez les verts mais sandrine
rousseau elle a quand même un pire
société civile en étant universitaires
mais aussi un pied dans le monde
politique en étant membre membre des
verts alors quel destin électoral pour
ces personnes qui sortent de l'ordinaire
michel alors pour le moment bon
évidemment ça plutôt mal tourné pour
tous les prétendants ou qui ont évité
bon je parlais des dix montant coluche
qui a été obligée de se retirer sous
l'effet de pressions politiques et de et
de menaces de mort un don qu'il retire
sa candidature en avril 81 bon il est
mort ne semble pas sensible aux
pressions il a déjà fait entendre que
effectivement il irait jusqu'au bout
donc je crois qu'il peut monter encore
un peu bon s'il a de l'ambition et si
les français le film il peut espérer se
rapprocher
ce rapproché de marine le pen alors vas
qu'il a dépassé bon 11 18 il a quand
même doublé son score en l'espace de
quelques semaines bon
on veut parfois le parallèle avec donald
trump bon tout est possible dans une
élection présidentielle mais est ce que
eric zemmour il peut être considéré
comme un candidat citoyen
en tant que représentants de la société
civile oui il incarne effectivement
cette appartenance citoyenne et
peut-être évidemment cette manière de
faire de la politique autrement de faire
la démocratie autrement donc quelque
part c'est aussi un peu à lire
paradoxalement l'esprit gilet jaune 1
voilà donc on dit les choses clairement
on veut des réponses des réponses
claires et nettes on ne veut plus le
mensonge
je pense que le monde politique est trop
assimilé à la langue de bois aux
manceaux
ont des claques on sera pas candidat ou
pas candidate et puis bon quelques mois
plus tard on est candidat voilà tous
tout ça tout ça ne plaît plus aux
français je pense qu'ils veulent
vraiment
quelqu'un de différent voilà et eric
zemmour est évidemment au delà encore
une fois tu sais de son idéologie
politique il peut séduire plus large
parce qu'il incarne évidemment toute
cette différence merci beaucoup michel
pour toutes ces explications sur le
phénomène d'eric zemmour merci merci